يطرق الجوع مجددا ابواب ملايين البشر مع
تزايد مخاوف عدم تمديد اتفاق البحر الاسود
والذي يضمن تصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه الى
العالم الاتفاق الذي يضم روسيا واوكرانيا
وتركيا وترعاه الامم المتحده تنتهي
صلاحيته في الثامن عشر من مايو في حال فشل
التجديد بالتزامن مع التلويح الروسي
بتعليقه انهاء الاتفاق يضرب اوكرانيا سله
العالم الغذائيه والتي اصلا تاثر قطاعها
الزراعي بطبيعات القصف الروسي فتراجعت
محاصيلها الى ادنى مستويات لها منذ عقد
انقر والامم المتحده فشلت بالحصول على
ضمانات تجديد الاتفاق فيما يستمر التقاذف
التهم بين موسكو وكيف حول الجهه المسؤوله
عن الازمه
انه امر مثير للاشمئزاز ان تتظاهر روسيا
انها الجانب الخاسر في الاتفاق ولن اذكر
المجلس بعدم اخلاقيه مثل هذه الشكاوى من
الدوله المعتديه والتي كانت ولا تزال
التهديد الوحيد لشحنات الغذاء في البحر
الاسود
حذرنا من اننا لا نستطيع المضيف الاتفاق
ان لم تتم معالجه القضايا التي تعيق
امدادات القطاع الزراعي الروسي تسعى الامم
المتحده الى دعم روسيا لتحقيق مطالبها
وانقاذ الاتفاق فموسكو تربط المضي
بازاله كل العراقيل امام صادراتها من
الحبوب والاسمده الى ذلك تطالب باستئناف
خط الانابيب الذي ينقل الامونيا الروسيه
الى موانئ اوكرانيا بالاضافه الى رفع
القيود المفروضه على المدفوعات والخدمات
اللوجستيه والتامين المرتبطه بالشحنات
فضلا عن اعاده ربط البنك الزراعي الروسي
بنظام سويفت العالمي للدفع غادرت اخر
السفن الغذائيه موانئ اوكرانيا بموجب
الاتفاق ليصل بذلك الى نهايته عمليا الا
ان محاولات احيائه تستمر لاسيما مع تضاعف
المخاوف على مستقبل القطع الزراعي
الاوكراني بسبب تاثيرات القصف والالغام
على خصوبه الاراضي الزراعيه الاوكرانيه